y'all remember back in the day when used
to freestyle battle people you got that
like they were deaf and blind [ __ ] look
listen if you weren't listening Oh what
is going on you sexy pieces of [ __ ]
triple F BAM yes and back you miss me
yeah you did no [ __ ] smash your pinky
toes now if you guys remember about
three weeks ago I told you that I threw
out my back but guess what I am now
officially fixed and I am back and I
feel good with a really good order trust
me friends ever since that injury you
have no idea how sorry I had been
looking because apparently if you had
your back it affects everything that you
do you try hitting on a girl with a
fucked-up back they don't know what the
hell they're looking at [ __ ] I'm a
person now recently through a lot of
messages and comments I had been reading
a lot of this what this person did and
hang on this other person be doing this
and they be a [ __ ] listen too many
times if I heard event about a lot of
you guys out there griping and
complaining about what other people have
and then you get discouraged but I will
break it down to you like this you are
not them for some reason when it comes
to your personal fitness you always like
to compare yourself to other people and
I don't know why listen the only person
that you are comparing yourself to on
the daily is the person that you were
yesterday that's it
your body your goals your life who the
[ __ ] cares where everyone else is at and
listen I get it we all have that one
friend that can eat whatever the [ __ ]
they want and always stay skinny son of
a [ __ ] but and we all know eventually
their metabolism will slow down and they
will get fat as [ __ ] and because you
have lost weight and you have lived a
healthier lifestyle you will know better
and you can go ahead and help them or if
you're anything like me I'm of those
Snickers that those [ __ ]
because for all the times that you ain't
pizza in front of me well I was dying
that's right [ __ ] I said it that's
right [ __ ] you thought I forgot didn't
you I forgive but I do not forget you
donut I said oh good
have to tell you this because you
already know that you cannot copy their
lifestyle and have their results right
let's let's be real we don't have their
body type they're a freak of [ __ ]
nature where the normal ones so you
gotta stop making excuses and saying
[ __ ] like well drag these Peas every day
and look at me hey well guess what the
next time you go see change you tell him
to go [ __ ] himself with a cactus because
you can't do that boo boo
you already know we've been eating pizza
all eyes and that's why we got fortunes
60 DS and more handled on her body and a
goddamn jungle gym when you are looking
to change your lifestyle and habits
especially when it comes to eating you
have to get rid of all those excuses you
can start a diet and you can start
working out but if you're not mentally
there you're just gonna go back to your
bad habits listen if you want this then
go make it happen nobody's waiting for
you you want that six-pack go get it you
want to be healthy to go do it you want
to take the dog peanut butter rub it on
the fetus is sticking and behind don't
do that no remember just focus on
yourself stop worrying about other
people don't worry about haters don't
worry about that other [ __ ] with
a six-pack [ __ ] you whatever hope it
gets hit by a car and buy me at the same
time and the beddings is balls off what
just do you focus get your mind right
and I guarantee it will happen for you
so jump o FM before I head out let me go
ahead and tell you about a little
challenge that I put upon myself now so
far I've lost a total about 22 pounds
which I am very very happy about now I
told you guys earlier that I hurt my
back and originally when I started this
I didn't have a weight-loss goal but I
did have a strength goal now because of
my injury that strength goal kind of you
know fool out the window so now I'm
flipping up my goal to a weight loss
goal now so what I'm doing for a little
bit of motivation and also another form
of accountability I am NOT going to cut
my hair until I reach one of my short
term goals now what is my short term
goal you ask it is to lose another 18
pounds to to let lost a total of 40
pounds
man you guys may think oh you're not
gonna cut your handle is that big deal
or something and take some [ __ ] if I
don't cut my hair dumper you things that
happen witness stop talking to me small
children and women run the [ __ ] away
from me I started to look like a North
Korean missionary and people start to
assume I can't speak English so I
challenge you guys to go ahead and make
the smuggle and do a little small
accountability thing for yourself to
what little challenge
I know that a lot of people like to do
if they're trying to lose weight is to
buy clothing as a size smaller I think
it's pretty dope that it's you know it's
safe so triple life and stay motivated
and I will see y'all next time and
remember life is always what you make it
but it's up to you to take what you
deserve
let's go for broke Oh what is going on
YouTube now yes you guys may or may not
have noticed some of the new gear are me
yes this is the monogram Tiffany teal a
bit broke summer hoodie that's right
this Friday we have three new releases
this is one of them we also have a
cherry blossom design and we also got a
heavenly baseball tee coming out which
is fresh as food and once again these
designs are very limited so they will go
out this is one of my favorite designs
as of yet
it's flies but I look cute Donna what's
up what's up today so good but anyways
guys funny fat fit is now bent and if
you guys are watching these videos make
sure that you hatch tag me on instagram
funny fat fit do that also on your
twitter and then hash tag it and connect
me to that too so i can check your
progress and keep you guys accountable
and support y'all because you guys have
to supporting me til next time buddy
benefit I will see y'all again copy gear
this little bit liberties look at this I
think I like this book quick I hate they
said oh there's hair being holding me
back what's up baby what's your name
what am i pastor nope I'll save you if
you want any better the only person that
you are supposed to cuz not conspire
conspirator the order I made up is
called conspiracy and compare compare so
go ahead state motive motive this same
model but same honor than a model stay
motive motive it why do I keep on saying
mode what the [ __ ] is motive you dumb
come on man Jesus mmm-hmm